98% 99 ja ich habe einen kleinen kino
den an alle meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen zurück zum boykott
galaxy wie ihr vielleicht aufgefallen
ist kamen gestern keine folge minecraft
kommt heute abend tritt und felix sind
auf die körper schreiber die sind in
allen partei das ist also ein bisschen
traurig ich hab mal überlegt ob die
partei wechseln soll
aber ich weiß gar nicht was funktioniert
die fraktion oder ob ihr das überhaupt
volt muss man alles noch aus finden
könnt ihr mal schreiben also ob ich
vielleicht aber die alle besucher weil
die anderen leute mag es viel lieber
ich habe einen dino und ein dino peder
was ich sagen wollte
gestern kam kann ein kräftiges zeichen
ganztag in dortmund war werdet ihr alles
in kontakt sehen der nächste konter geht
richtig richtig groß und ich werde meine
ganze woche dann quasi mal so zeigen was
ich da eine ganze woche gemacht habe da
nicht ein auto war wo ich überall
hingelaufen benutzer wird der stand ist
echt ein bisschen crazy aber zeigt auf
jeden fall mein stand im projekt ich
habe die am ende gut ich wollte nur
sagen dass heute abend die minecraft
kommen also dass ihr euch ja keine
sorgen machen braucht morgen abend kommt
auch noch ein cooles video da kommt
nämlich wer wird die region eher runde
zwei ich war schon mal mit dabei und da
war ich jetzt noch mal dabei das werde
ich dann auch hochladen dann ja das wird
dann kommen und dann ich habe eigentlich
die nächsten tage macht die coole videos
am start also wenn ich das alles schaffe
ich habe auch ein bisschen mehr zeit
ich habe meinen trip nach london ich
habe jetzt ein trip nach london gebucht
dann werde ich in london auch richtig
richtig für film und dann so ein richtig
großes follow me round in london machen
das wird richtig richtig geil glaube ich
hoffe ich mal was ist dass man brake
china werde ich dann richtig geiles
follow me round in london machen
ich hoffe dass das cool wird ich denke
dass das cool wird weil schauen wie das
leuchten an kommentiert gibt mal gibt
nicht ein daumenbruch das zeigt mir gar
nichts schreibt einen kommentar ob das
überhaupt wollte nicht dass er sagt ja
kommen genießt lieber deinen tag
internist und ja egal ich werde auf
jeden fall versuchen das wissen was sie
zu fällen okay die schreiben die gehen
einfach ohne zu schreiben okay so gut
ich wollte jetzt erstmal meinen dino
ausschöpfen lassen und zwar hier und da
ich jetzt eine den op dee habe mache ich
es ok browsers diese steht bei minus 4
ja gut ich werde dann auf jeden fall
hier in der nähe sein damit dieser
velociraptor das ist der wird am anfang
ihr werdet euch wundern wie klein dieses
teil ist da werde ich euch denken was
für ein scheiß die du aber wenn er
später groß ist dann ist das mein kind
das von anfang an mein kind dass mein
kleiner papi nennen nämlich paddington
spät den pending neben den kleinen kino
habe ich mir überlegt ich habe ja schon
gesagt wie ihr so alle jahren in den
stehenden die so bla bla bla bla wie ich
nenne ihn penning in paddington ist ein
cooler name finde ich wenn ich einen
hund hätte würde ich auch berlin nennen
so acht sein das heißt ich kann mir noch
eben fahrzeuge machen
blablabla hier sind das dann noch ein
bisschen dankl mutter soll dann macht
mir das jetzt ein bass ticks hier nix da
raus sodass diese sticks mache ich mir
ich weiß gar nicht wie viel zu lange
brauche ich denn nicht noch mal einfach
ja ich mache mal einfach irgendwas total
besoffen ist hier so dann setzte er sein
fahrzeug vor
ich wollte nämlich ich habe mir echt
sorgen gemacht wer hört hört ich habe
mir die diamanten gedanken gemacht
hört hört sehr krass wie geil ist ich
muss auf jeden fall
10.12 wieso hat er denn erst - 18
vielleicht weil er so ein bisschen
anders kann aber vielleicht lag das auch
daran dass ich am anfang nicht diese
deen op de hat und das kontrollieren
konnte jedenfalls geht es relativ
schnell ich denke in dieser folge werden
wir schon seinen ersten eigenen dino
haben werde wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gelesen haben weil ich dass er
wieder so ganz groß stolz da
reingeschrieben habe ich haben die nur
freunde
hier sollte eigentlich der dino stall
hinkommen so neben mal ein bettchen
ich muss das alles war so ein bisschen
gucken wie ich das alles auch baue ich
finde übrigens sehr scheiße das sind
auch alles gründe warum ich eigentlich
funktion wechseln will dass sich leute
einfach über mich bauen und alles
möglich ich hoffe einfach dass es unter
mir noch frei bleibt weil ich zeige euch
das jetzt mal ganz kurz was ich machen
wollte was ich mir vorm schlafengehen
überlegt habe hier mache ich so eine
kleine treppe oder ich weiß ich das hier
mache oder hier bietet sich ja
eigentlich an weil das ist genau der
bitte geht an sondern leiter nach unten
oder leiter oder treppe ich weiß gar
nicht vielleicht manch einer leiter das
ganz cool
und dann habe ich quasi da unten seinen
riesigen raum er ist dann quasi hier und
da werde ich dann diese farmen bauen
weil diese fahne der immer so ein
bisschen platz wegnimmt dann wenn ich
den ganzen farm riesig hinbauen einen
kompletten streifen hier ich hab mir
sachen aufgeschrieben einen kompletten
streifen erdbeeren einen kompletten
streifen kakao und alles kakao kaffee
kaffee kaffee und das werde ich dann da
alles errichten und dann wird hat
eigentlich alles ganz cool werden
hoffe ich und
dann möchte ich das irgendwann bleib
studie machen nicht im livestream
sondern in einer 1 stunden folge machen
und diese 1 stunden folge werde ich
wahrscheinlich sogar heute noch
aufnehmen wird auch alles alleine sein
weil ich dann am produktivsten bin ich
schaue mal ob ich dir heute noch
aufnehme
ich muss hier hat die ganze zeit in der
nähe sein und kann nichts anderes machen
weil das gleich schlüpft freunde meine
kiste das kann ich doch eben die kisten
sortiert die ganze scheiße cobblestone
der wir hier mal ausgegraben wird solch
packe ich einfach mal alles gefallen ich
brauche ich nicht noch so ein paar holz
sondern sachen rein sondern gehe ich
ganz schnell wieder zum diener ich muss
nämlich im umkreis von sechs blöcken zu
den velociraptor sein damit der direkt
mein freund jetzt und freunde sind live
dabei
gleichschritt ein dino jedenfalls wenn
ganz viele sachen machen die hier am
haus verändert werden acht nicht im
livestream der ein stunden folge 98
prozent 99
ich habe einen kleinen kino guckt euch
den an meine freunde hier noch benutzt
ihr habt doch hallo hallo pelletier 2
paddington verlinken lokaler schlucken
jetzt mache ich gleich noch ein game tag
den ich in paddington und ich wollte
stone tablet sie an den rand machen
indem dino stall das den kleinen ball
ins labor krieger hallo dino buchner
hand gegeben hätte land ist also der
kann dies eröffne das ist nämlich ein
fleischfresser das heißt wenn der
schweine in der nähe hat damit die
schweine töten und das essen und sonst
kann ich immer was in der hand geben
der hat 1925 also ich denke ich jetzt
warum ist dann noch so kleinen gerät
später drei blöcke hoch glaube ich so
und dann kann ich sie darauf ich weiß
ihr euch darauf reiten kann aber er wird
später genauso nun größer und dann grün
vielleicht und alles mögliche und
wahrscheinliche auf dem jetzt folgt das
wäre ja nicht so cool wenn der hat
übrigens noch meine deen op die an der
hand das finde ich sehr komisch
dass der gegner eine hand kriegt wenn
ich das mal mache wenn ich denn ich
wollte ich nicht dass zum thema der mag
mich nein der war gar nicht gezähmt das
war die sache der war gar nicht gezähmt
der greift mich jetzt an online
der war gar nicht gezähmt scheiß jetzt
muss dir noch irgendwie zähmen musst du
irgendwas zu fressen geben habe ich den
park oder so das ist ein fleischfresser
aber jetzt habe ich da keinen kopf hier
war noch direkt daneben als sehr
gespannt ist deswegen wollte ich diesen
nedbal machen dass ich mir schweine
holen kann und so was alles park hatte
mich davon erzählt safari net so heißt
das dann gleich safari mit allen
landesteilen planet ziemlich noch in den
letzten sieben minuten das nicht nur ein
höhe ist dass hilfe so hart diese
mysteriöse schiebt lässig aber das ist
mir wieder alles komplizierter auf
jedenfalls lions das ist die hauptsache
das brauche ich nämlich auch für den
namen tag allerdings kann ich dir dann
quasi erst dann wenn ich wirklich
irgendwie den gezähmt habe das muss ja
dann erst mal machen
ich dachte eigentlich wenn ich direkt
daneben denn wenn der schlips dass er
mich mag aber anscheinend nicht oder der
macht nämlich und ich hab den
angeschlagen jetzt hast du mich so das
kann ja auch sein wissen dass hier für
holz das sehr komisch aus
es wird tintenfische überall kindes
gedacht dass hier irgendwas bleibt sind
wenn das hier so ein bisschen luftiger
ist daher sehe ich nur nach ananas abbas
lions sind hier gar nicht so
habe ich dann schon habe ich dann schon
irgendwo islams gefunden weiß ich gar
nicht schreibt mir das mal bitte wo ich
nehme berliner bz
ich weiß noch gar nicht kann ich mit
meinen apples kann ich die phrasen hallo
leckersten ihr sowas ist dass er hierfür
der region
es ist die leg region bestimmt jetzt lag
dass ihr die ganze zeit da will ich auch
nich anmuten minuten minuten
deswegen sehr cool aus wie das monster
von loch ness so dass der kopf da oben
sind sind sie krabbeln schnecken
wesentlich höher schlagen
der sockel alles ein bisschen hier
plötzlich was das für millionen ist
siehst du auf jeden fall nicht so wär
sympathisch und ich brauche auf jeden
fall slams berichtet dann herkriegen
kann ich finde ich wie herstellen oder
so bleiben wo wir zusammen geschrieben
ich muss irgendwie tiere mit kriegen und
dafür brauche ich ein safari und dieses
erfahrene geht wohl nur mit life balls
oder ich muss einfach so tiere töten und
gibt die dem dann zu fressen
dann soll er einfach die tiere dann
fressen ist das denn das hat einfach nur
auf das hat auch nicht verwunderlich so
einen schalter da fragen wir nämlich
immer ich hab doch schon mal ein schaf
getötet wie so verwende ich mich denn
jetzt in den charts das ergibt für mich
einfach das sind so sachen die für mich
einfach keinen sinn ergeben
solche seiner schafe sind irgendwo noch
bei elf minuten muss er noch die freude
dann auch fossilien mal an ich glaube
ich lasse auch gleich erstmal den
anderen ich habe noch den dna dann mache
ich mir daraus noch ein ei oder lasst
den auch noch beruhigt und dann habe ich
noch eine ganz machen wir dann unseren
riesigen kino stark durch aber angst
wenn ich dann wirklich irgendwann
umziehen sollte das dann wirklich alles
irgendwie mit kriegen muss in neue
wohnungen meine allerdings welche uns
hier boa sketchen kappe und außerdem ein
bisschen die haben ja gegeben ja auch
fleißig vollidiot wahrscheinlich wieder
an den kommentaren wird jedoch dünner
und ich fliege jetzt wieder vorbei gebt
mir eure fleisch oder fressen die wohl
hühner die dinos falls nicht natürlich
auf jeden fall noch testen wenn ich
sterben
so dass noch fleisch
so am besten einfach schwein aber ich
weiß ist die schweine auf jeden fall
fressen und ich kann auch einen fehler
machen der feeder ist etwas wo sich die
dinos dann nachher futter rausnehmen
wenn sie gerade in der umgebung das
werde ich aber erst machen wenn ich ganz
viele dinos ab
sieht sehr schön hier raus übrigens hier
ist wieder sondern wie die hellen baby
turtle auf den kopf ok cool dass wir
schicken das übrigens sehr sehr schön
hier immer noch dieses stein mit dem
ganzen blauen wasser hier ist ja nicht
so tiefes wasser sondern ist ja nur so
ein paar blättchen hoch hier zeigen die
sehr schön hier mag ich auch dass hier
weißt du dich finde ich sehr sehr sehr
sehr geil so ein kleiner lagune weisen
ich würde viel lieber einfach aber gar
nicht jessen mit der über erwerb wird
viel lieber irgendwie hier sowohl das
ist richtig schön sondern so ein neues
bio die stars 12 minuten30 mal nach
hause
ich finde ich sehr sehr schön hier so
die ganze landschaft mag ich gefällt mir
mache ich mir vielleicht mal eine
ferienresidenz in burma kuba ist jedoch
irgendwie wartet man töten könnte obwohl
ich dir eigentlich für meine milch so
ein bisschen ja auch noch brauche aber
das finde ich wohl noch irgendwo auf der
karte für heute ist mit den taschen
wieder so eklig voll war das eure
kollegen sonst am wasser
so noch irgendwo eine kuh die macht nun
auch nicht dort noch eine kuh was
interne laufen kommt jetzt ein megatrend
of pop megatrend also ich weiß dass ich
keine einer eigentlich gerade eine kuh
am leben lassen sollen oder zwei damit
er sich pal oder mit neu entstehen und
die evolution fortgesetzt wird aber
jetzt gebe ich meinen die nur noch immer
zu fressen damit er dann nicht total
verhungert ich hoffe ja nur ich fenster
so scheiße wenn wir dieser dino auch
wieder geklaut wird wir werden ja so
viele das übrigens auch noch so ein
leader irgendwann mitnehmen ich finde es
ja echt so kacke wenn wir wirklich
irgendwann mal was geklaut wird wir
wurden ja schon so ein paar sachen
glaube ich geglaubt man alt ist die nur
alles ja weg irgendwie aber das kann
auch sein das ist einfach da lang daran
lag dass das nicht mit der din en pdf
abgespeichert habe sein kollege du
kriegst hat immer was zu fressen bist
immer noch böse auf mich
das kann böse das ja schön sollte kriegt
das etwas zu fressen in der hand fühlt
sich okay
wieso willst du dich in hand nehmen hat
der schnee hat er auch nicht oder willst
du das hier denn vielleicht gar nix ich
probier's mal mit den op die am tamed
wie kriege ich denen jetzt tamed du
bleibst auf jeden fall erstmal hier
ich stelle ihm da jetzt meine kiste hin
mit bisschen was zu fressen habe ich
jedoch nicht noch kisten liegen
ich stelle ihnen da erst mal eine kiste
hin
ich tue man da so ein paar sachen rein
ich muss auch die folge jetzt sofort
wieder beenden so fossilien sollte man
übrigens sparen wurde mir auch gesagt
weil dann die chance größer ist 8,46
wundervoll
dann würde ich aber nicht sondern
ausbrüten ich glaube ich nehme doch eine
folge galaxies brachiosaurus einer
rausrücken will dass der am wenigsten
state ist ein bisschen so weit wollte
ich denn jetzt bei dem machen was ich
wollte meine kiste hinstellen dass der
sich selber was zu fressen aussehen kann
weil da stand die hörende baut opel
inzests dann packt ihn einfach eine
kiste mit so ein bisschen was zu fressen
hin wenn das nicht und dann habe ich
selber noch das essen und dann kann er
sich daher so ein bisschen was raus will
solch packt dem einfach die sachen
erzählen warum halten uns sind das
vielleicht
komm nicht klassiker einfach nix naja
ich lasse ich einfach da drinstehen
licht aber zu essen ost-berlin lebt
freunde ich würde sagen wir sehen uns in
der nächsten folge minecraft galaxy
wieder wenn es euch gefallen hat zeigt
und einmalig schreibt mir vielleicht in
die kommentare wie ich den themen kann
ich gucke mit auch im internet an
neben jetzt nochmal folge minecraft
galaxy auf die kommt dann aber erst
morgen unternehmens noch die minecraft
auf die kommen dann allerdings heute
abend gegen 8 uhr also denke ich und
dann würde ich sagen muss schon
wunderschön